abone ol
bu
Merhabalar ben Uçan top Günaydın
tutkunun Al bugün
meteoroloji eğitimi nasıl dönüştürecek
başlığına aktaracağım bildiğiniz gibi şu
anda her birey meteor tartışıyor ve Ani
oldu aslında baktığımız zaman
Facebook'un ismi değiştim et oldu ve
aniden ve Toros nedir ne değildir
avatarlar mekanlar nft ile arsa satın
almalar gibi pek çok yeri çekilmeye
çalışılır tam olarak nedir dan eğitime
nasıl dönüştüreceğiz bize doğru böyle
bir götürmek istiyorum sizleri wap 20
teknolojileri ile gelen etkileşimli
ortamı biliyoruz şu anda zaten yaygın
uygulaması bizler için sosyal medya
uygulamaları dijital oyunlar ve bir
sanal Evren var ama gerçek yaşam
etkilemiyor baktığımız zaman şu an bu
açılan şey vp30 ne olacak Meta ve meteor
istediğimiz şey ne olacak nereye doğru
gidiyoruz evleniyoruz dolaşıma bugün
dönüşüm demek istedim Çünkü metaforas
bir arayüz aracılığıyla bizim
gidebileceğimiz Avatar larımızı temsil
edilebileceği miz fakat gerçek yaşamı
etkileyecek bir evrenden bahsediliyor
Dolayısıyla metafors Öncelikle tanımını
merak ediyorum mesela herkes meteos
dendiği zaman Aslında bunu bir ekosistem
olduğunu anlatıyoruz Hadi bunu nasıl
anlayıp anlatacağız nasıl tartışacağız
birinci adımımız bu
şu an uygulama yapıyoruz desek Çok doğru
bir yaklaşım olmaz çünkü altyapı
gerekiyor her bireyin kendi anahtarını
tasarlaması her biri Kesin yine aynı
şekilde o mekanlarda tanışık olmasını
içeriğine bakın eğitimin Mesela en can
alıcı noktası öğretimsel iç ve o
simülatif deneyim lenecek ortamdan hazır
olması gerekiyor Dolayısıyla gerçekçi
baktığımız zaman bir geçiş diyerek
anlama ve anlatma kısımlarını deneyelim
metrobüs ekosisteminde artırılmış
gerçeklik Yapay Zeka İşte gördüğünüz
zaman sanal gerçeklik hibrit olanı
genişletilmiş gerçeklik gibi pek çok
kavramı içerdiğini söyleyebiliriz
metrobüsten ilan yine gerçek Ötesi Evren
Ötesi yine bir Metropol çalışması
yapmıştık Aslında insanların aklında şu
anda çok soyut kaldığını fark ettik ya
çok soğutmasi hayal rüyada Evren Ötesi
gerçek Ötesi gibi böyle daha soyut böyle
bir çağrışım var algılama var insanlar
arasında ve ne olacağını Gerçekten
hepimiz çok merak ediyoruz ve tam olsun
tek başına bir tanımını yapmak bence
mümkün değil yani meteor sün kendi
içerisinde ayrı ayrı teknolojilerin
olduğu ve bu doğru ve şu anda deneyim
dediğimiz şeylerin Aslında çoğunun
artırılmış gerçeklik olduğunu
söyleyebiliriz mesela çok duyuyorum
Samet thanos dilimleyelim hadi gelin
anahtarınızı tasarlıyorum hizmet
veriyorsa koyacağız böyle bir şey yok
yani meteor sürü deneyimlemek için
sadece bir gözlükle ve elimizde
tuttuğumuz aparatlarla bunu deneyim
dememiz mümkün mü Ne fark edecek ne
bekliyoruz baktığımız zaman bizlerin
duyarlı hassas kıyafetleri giyilebilir
teknolojilere hep dik eldivenleri hep
dik duyarlı bir hepsi cloves dediğimiz
eldivenler rahiplik kıyafetlerle o
mekânlara geçiş yapmamız ve masa
tokalaştımı zaman işte onu hissetmemiz
gerekiyor veya bir araya ateşe
yaklaştığımız zaman ateşin bana
sıcaklığını hissetmem gerekiyor veya
daha başka ne olur musun bir müzede
gözlükle gezmek etrafındaki nesnelere
bakma kart o gerçeklik uygulamasıdır ve
bu meteoroloji değildir ne zaman ve ters
olur yani biz buna ne zaman meteoroloji
diyebiliriz ancak o müzedeki
eşyalara Yani oradaki nesnelere
dokunduğumuz zaman ve onu hissettiğimiz
zaman yani bu yine bahsettiğimiz
giyilebilir eldivenlerle Mümkün olabilir
fakat biz burada artırılmış gerçeklik
deneyimini dönem istiyoruz artırılmış
gerçeklik bunun bir ekosistem bir
parçası ve deneyim dememiz çok önemli
sanal gerçeklik cihazları Evet yani
şimdi bu metrosu olduğu zaman Aslında
fiziksel kısımdan yani Fiziksel ortamda
zahmet harcamadan Mesela işte otobüse
bindik ve arabamıza bindik ve bir
fiziksel mekana gitmeyeceğiz de bizler
evden Gözlük veya Hatta onun küçülmesini
beklediğimizi dans larımızı gözümüze
takarak hep dik duyarlı kıyafetlerimizi
giyerek o deneyimi yaşamanız gerekiyor
bir sürü da gitti ulaşmamız gerekiyor
veya bir okula gidip
gitmek yerine evden okulda oldu ya
Kampüsü hissetmem gerekiyor ve Dersim
almam gerekiyor Dolayısıyla Bunların
hepsi aslında bir teknik çalışmayı
gerektiriyor teknik altyapı eksikliğini
burada artık vurgulamak lazım şu an
hazır değil olduğunu söyleyebiliriz Evet
bunlarla ilgili mesela herkesi daha
ulaşılabilir yine bu lafların
giyilebilir teknolojilerin kıyafetlerin
ulaşması Herkesin kendi vatanı yapması
gibi kolaylıkların oluşması içerik var
mı simülatif deneme yanılma
eğitim-öğretim içerikleri müfredat var
mı Bunu da hazırlamak gerekiyor bakın
manca 7 can alıcı noktası burada içerik
mekan tasarlanır üç boyutlu
grafikerlerin işte yaptığı avatarlar ve
kanunlar Bunlar yapılır ama burada en
önemli şey metrosun pedagojisi yani
metrobüsün nasıl bir öğretimsel
felsefesinin olacağı bakın metrobüs
pedagojisi bu kavramlar konseptler
tartışı olduk ya Daha dün Pedagoji
varken Bugün bunun meteoroloji nasıl
olacağını Çünkü birazdan israfçı Design
dediğimizi Öğretim salatası modellerinde
dönüşeceğini ve dönüşmesi gerektiğine
konuyu getireceğiz bir metre evrenden
bahsediyoruz bu Evren şu anda dediğimiz
gibi geçiş tartışma
aşamasındayız Facebook realiti lapsi
yöneten Android şöyle söylemiş en az
İşte 10-15 hadi onu ibrası kenar 15 yıl
diyelim on beş yıl sonra biz bunu ancak
belki deneyim söyleyebiliriz Demir
iyimser bakış açısında bulunmuş
baktığımız zaman 15 yıl sonra Acaba ne
olacak ve ters olursa o zaman meteor
suyun içinde doğacak kuşak var ve tavus
kuşu olacak Hadi günümüzde sosyal medya
ile doğmuş büyümüş kişilere bizi sosyal
medya kuşağı diyorsak o zaman Hedef
kitlenizi ne Bakın bu sefer meteor ise
Doğanlar ya da gemiler da diyebiliriz
mesela avatarla tanışıklığı ve de o
dükkanda doğmuş bebeklerde meteor
sciuscia diyeceğiz ben şöyle düşündüm
açıkçası şu anda sosyal medya kuşağı
dijital oyunlar zaten çalışır Bu evreni
kimler yapacak bizim şu anda bu Evren
imizi sosyal medya kuşağı Yani daha
böyle genç bireylerin işsizlerin ve
sizlerden sonra gelecek nesillerin inşa
etmesi bekleniyor bunu evrende doğacak
kişilerde meteos kuşağı olarak zaten
tanışıp olarak Doğuş açın ve ki de
yadırgama yapacaklar Aslında böyle
baktığımız zaman hani adaptasyon dönemi
var Onlar direk adapte olarak dünyaya
gelecekler ve tablosu artırılmış
gerçeklik mi ya bu farkı Bence dikkat
etmek gerekiyor günümüzde nefesiyle arsa
satın almak demektir e kadar kavram indi
böyle bir şey değil olduğunu meteor Sun
Sadece böyle büyük gözlüklerle
deneyimlenen ve bir ortamdan fazlasını
gerektirdiğini bu fazlalığını çok
duyarlı kıyafetler yan dokunma ve onu
yaşam Ah ismi his hisi duyma kısmının
önemli olduğunu vurgulamak lazım bize
örneği vermiştik yani dokunmak temas
etmek hissetmek Duygu paylaşımında
bulunmak Hatta iletişimde bilir annesi
tokalaşma ve mimiklerimiz ifade eden
etkili iletişimde hep örnek veriniz
bunların önemli olduğunu ve sadece sözlü
iletişim değil insanın duygularının da
karşı tarafa
geçtiği bir takım şimdi Ümitler
hareketler duruş bunları meteor
ortamında nasıl olacağını adapte etmek
gerekiyor Yani bir yer gözlüğü takıp
girdiğimiz ortamlarda Biz artırılmış
gerçeklik dememiz gerekiyor
rahmetle ortaöğretim nasıl olacak bizim
en önemli problemi miz bu olacak
Eğitimciler için burada modeller zaten
vardı günümüzde ilearning ve eğitim
yazılımları eğitim CD'leri yapıyorduk
hatta bir ara Bunlar da biri bu akşam
designmodo dediğimiz öğretimsel tasarım
modelleri vardı Eve bu modelleri
izleyerek işlem basamakları sistem
sürecinde yapılırdı tasarlanır the şimdi
Bu modellerin dönüşmesi gerekecek Biz
daha çok Diner dan ziyade katmanlı
modelden bahsedeceğiz yani katman katman
üstüne inşa edeceğimiz dizel motorları
ihtiyacımız olacak Ve bu da yarısını
yeni meslekleri doğuracağını
söyleyebiliriz Yani üç boyutlu bir
evrene göre tasarlanması gerektiği için
eğitimin bizlerin mesela metafors
instructional dizaynı gibi yani meteor
Öğretim tasarımcısı gibi mesleklere
ihtiyacımız olacak yine Avatar tasarımı
üç boyutlu grafiker grafik tasarım gibi
yeni bilim dalları yeni meslekler
ihtiyacımız olacak
modele geçmeden önce şunu vurgulamak
istiyorum çok daha yukarıdan atıp
tutmaya Bence gerek yok baktığımız zaman
Yapay Zeka doğuşundan örnek vereceğim
yani önümüze çok çarpıcı örnek Balcı bu
bu yapay zekanın doğuşu da nasıl
bilimsel olana girişi 1956 yani Yapay
Zeka şu anda çok müthiş şeyler yapıyordu
bir garip doğduğu zamanı Biz gidecek
olursan
1956'da bilimsel alanda tartışılmaya
başlanıyor anneme tavası olduğu gibi şu
anda tartıştığımız gibi
18 yıl geçiyor az önce de yine
meteoroloji sıra karşılaştırıyorum 15
yıl demişler Dream
daha sonra 18 yıl sonra Ya insanlar
yatırım yapıyor iş meslek dalları
yatırım yapıyor şirket siyahları yatırım
yapıyor Yapay Zeka çok müthiş şeyler
yapacak insanüstü ve insanların
başaramayacağı şeyleri kısa sürede ve
daha zeki sistemler yapacak gibi bir
balon gibi çok fazla şey vaad ediliyor
Daha sonra bir rapor hazırlanıyor ve bu
eleştirel raporda Aslında bu
söylenenlerin hiçbir şey ya hani
oluşmadığını yani bakıyorlar Ortada
hiçbir şey yok ve 18 yıl sonra Yapay
Zeka denilen şeyin sadece bir patr aç
Bilgisayarda bir satranç programı
olduğunu görüyorlar Tabii ki şu anda
günümüzde karşılaştırmak bu yani mümkün
değil yani Günümüzde çok önemli
gelişmeler Tabii ki var fakat ilk
doğuşundan bahsediyoruz burada aybiyem
indi Blue isimli ve dünya satranç
şampiyonu yenen bir sadece satranç
programından ibaret bir şey oldu 18 yıl
sonra ve bunun altına Yapay Zeka kışı
bir dedi Yani insanlar birden Soğuk duş
etkisi ile karşılaştılar yapay zeka kışı
dediler buna yani beklentiler oluşmadı
daha sonra yıllar sonra Tabi ki bu
değişiyor 1987 93 yıllarında yine iş
dünyasını bunu çok İlgilendiğin çok
büyük sermayelerin yatırıldığını
görüyoruz Ve tabii ki günümüze
baktığımız zaman da işte Bu sıra kalsın
hücrelerinin Bakıp Bir doktordan daha
çabuk daha hızlı teşhis koyduğunu çok
akıllı sistemlerin olduğunu günümüzde
iyi bir noktada olduğunu söyleyebiliriz
şimdi baktığımız zaman
meteort nereye gidiyor en az onbeş yıl
sonra alırım veya işte bazı uzmanların
da belirttiği gibi çok yolumuz var Evet
teknolojik altyapıya ihtiyacımız var
avatarlar gerekiyor içerik Pedagoji
gerekiyor dedik belki işte bir Kampüsün
artık fiziksel bir Mekandan ibaret
olmayacağını artık Böyle sanal bir
evrende evde oturduğumuz yerden
üniversiteye işe gidecek liseye gidecek
öğrenciler evden bütün gün o büyük
gözlüklerde olmayacak müfredatına
önünde bulacak böyle birşey bekliyoruz
değil mi Tabii ki yani bu kadar Yapay
Zeka neyimiz var yani 15 yıl sonra
olması mümkün mü bu Muhtemelen 15 yıl
sonra bir metrobüs kişi yaşanacak
olabilir yani bu teknolojinin oturması
ve çok gel bu geçmesi büyük öneme sahip
oluyor Dolayısıyla artırılmış gerçeklik
deneyimleri bize alışkanlık deneyimleme
sağlayacak fakat tam olarak motorsun bu
üniversitelerin yerine geçmesi veya işte
bir
Hipermarket in bir sinemanın yerine
geçmesi için büyük kıştan geçmemiz
gerekiyor ama ortaya bir şey çıkacak mı
Evet çıkacak ve Ama bu yavaş yavaş
gelişecek bir kaç kişi sonra belki
bahara ulaşıp Bu da aynı şekilde Yapay
Zeka da olduğu gibi bir noktaya illaki
yıllarda gelecek bak öretim tasarımı
dediğimiz zaman beni modele dayanır brüt
üç boyutlu Evren olduğu için
meteorolojin üç boyutlu Hatta
uyumlaştırılmış bir sistemi yakın olduğu
için üç boyutlu iyi bir Öğretim tasarımı
modeli ihtiyaç var ilk yapılan
çalışmalarda iki boyutlu ya göre şu an
Elimizde olan bitter ile 12 firmaları ve
Hava Eğitim yazılımları kullandığı
modeller var ama bazı modellerin Hatta
böl geliştiğini görüyoruz biz bunları
eğitim CD'leri yaptığımız zamanlarda
kullanıyorduk görev analizi işte
öğretimsel analiz bir eğitim-öğretim
kısımları gelişmiş olduğu iki boyutlu
dijital ortamda bu şekilde modellerle
çalışıyorduk şimdi meteor ise geldiğimiz
zaman üç boyuta bunları oturmuyor Bakın
şimdi yeni bir model ihtiyacımız var
yani bizim üç boyutlu sisteme Entegre
olacak ilk çalışma kapkara kapı not
metrobüs adapte ederek bir çalışma
yapmış ya yurt dışında bir çalışmayı
karşılaştım Burada yine İshak şimdi
Grande Yani en ortada bakım Öğretim
tasarım veya Öğretim var öğretim merkezi
yani Eyüp burada eğitim-öğretim metross
pedagojisinin oturması gerekiyor
eğitim-öğretim felsefesinin oturması
gerekiyor ve bu öğretimde daha çok
simülatif olması bekleniyor katılımcı
Merkez yargı çıkıp birşey anlatmıyorum
Bu simülasyonlar da kullanıcı kendi veya
iki ile beraber deneyeceğiz birer
sistemi gitmesi gerekiyor
böyle baktığımız zaman katman katman
gidecek yani Demin ki az önce baktım
zaman linaya dümdüz giden modellerden
ziyade en altı tabakadan en üst İnşa
ederek katmanlı modellerle çalışmamız
gerekecek bunu etrafında da katılımcı
Merkezi bu Avatar fıstık Avatar Merkez
atarım da girdim ve avatarı Merkezi alan
katılımcı Merkezi simülatif işbirlikçi
bir ekip çalışması ve işbirliğinin önemi
giderek artacak Çünkü orada her biri
için simülatif ortamın olması mümkün
olmayacak bir belki masa etrafında
toplanıp tek bir simülasyon ortamında
ekiple işbirliği yapmak gerekecek
baktığımız zaman katmanlar var böyle bu
şekilde anlayışı sahip sonra hızlıca
geçelim Makro Yapı katmanı ve yine
burada yıl deneyim burada Bu arada artık
öğren yani öğrenilecek içeriye sıkmaması
simülasyonu devamlı tepki vermesi kişiye
göre kişinin hızına göre kapasitesine
göre tepki vermesi aynı oyunlarda olduğu
gibi sürpriz Action ların olması
gerekiyor otiva syonu sağlayalım duysa
motivasyon çalışmalarını da ayrıca
planlamak gerekiyor Bu sistem daha çok
oyunlarda kullanılan sisteme benziyor
baktığımız zaman yapı olarak dolu size
daha uyumlaştırılmış daha simülatif daha
işbirlikçi ve oradaki tamamen
pedagojinin doğru oturması önemli bu
modelleri ihtiyaç var Bu Bir Oyun
modelinden adapte edilmiş belki yenisini
geliştireceğiz 15 yıl sonra belki bu da
olmayacak yenisini geliştireceğiz ama
bir tane böyle bir örnek En azından
görmüş olalım keşif deneyim temsil
avatarla Yazıcı takipçilerimize temsil
edilip burada daha çok mı gideceğiz
deneyim diyeceğiz Ali tepkiler verecek
sistemleri ihtiyacımız var Tamamen
duyarlı kıyafetleri ihtiyacımız var
hepimizin evine girmesi gerekiyor Yani
hep dik dediğimiz eldivenler kıyafetler
bunlara hepinizin ulaşması gerekiyor ki
o duyarlar maaşı tokalaşma örneği
verebiliriz
simülasyonda mesela o sıcaklık soğukluk
hissi ne hissetmem gibi böyle tek
örnekler verebiliriz
Evet toparlayacak olursak bak meteor
usta eğitim Kolay olmayacak yani tek
böyle bir sunum açtık birisi bize
anlattı doluysa çok büyük bir hazırla
ihtiyacımız var Eğitimciler olarak
Öncelikle Bu modellerin tasarlanması ve
Belki bir üniversite verdiğini
bölümlerin açılması ve bu tasarım
alanların oluşması tasarımcıların
yetiştirilmesi bunların tamamen böyle üç
boyuta adapta olarak yani katmanlı
modeller şekilde çalışması gerekiyor
oyunlaştırılmış simülatör İyi akşamlar
ve bu Pedagoji sahip olmak gerekiyor
böyle bir oradaki vardım hile bilir
hayatım açısından dedik Batman teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]